il n'aura suffi que de cette saison pour
faire de juste fontaine une figure
emblématique du football français à 70
ans est un jeune retraité qui nous
reçoit chez lui dans sa maison
toulousaine remplie de souvenirs de la
tapisserie à l'assiette nominative en
passant par la légion d'honneur juste en
a reçu des récompenses pour un ex au
mondial encore inégalée 13 buts marqués
en une seule coupe du gauche celui où
tout le monde se souvient c'est le
premier but
l'égalisation contre le brésil parce que
le brésil avait joué quatre matchs sans
prendre un but
ils menaient 1 0 et donc on a égalisé
donc quand on projette des images
une seule image à cause du monde on
projette ce but qui était d'ailleurs un
très joli but mais bon
mais en fait c'est 13 thébaux 1958 la
dass et inoubliable et les anecdotes
aussi pour la coupe du monde mais que
trois maillots pour faire 6 matchs donc
il a fallu relever parce que il n'est
pas prévu qu'on irait si loin si vous
dire s'il est optimiste et le plus beau
c'est que ce record est battu avec les
chaussures de mort en passant mes
chaussures rendu l'âme
donc j'ai marqué 13 buts avec ses
chaussures et à la fin de compétition
gelé rendu les chaussures et je pense
qu'elles sont devenues ils ont dû
terminer le 13 buts le chiffre l'a
poursuivie pendant toute sa carrière
comble du hasard sa maison est située au
numéro 13 bondi que ça porte malheur
je me suis effectivement cassé la jambe
après ça c'est la destinée c'est au
maroc y avait un mot qui résume et tout
ça c'était mecteau que ça veut dire
c'est le destin
les quarante cinq angles son record de
buts en coupe du monde seront fêtés
dignement avec les plus grands
beckenbauer di stéfano ou encore platine
toutes ces stars qui ont fait l'histoire
du football